who goes forever for a few first alright
oh this is a sad one it's gonna take a
lot of a lot of wheat I won't be
emotionally Barnett but it yeah is that
first one two men I know I know like
when you watch like a shot you know
dying dog movie do you cry every time
absolutely not every tithing well yeah I
guess his ear bud said dog heaven all
dogs go to heaven to them yeah those are
the bad head oh good dog it's like the
movement title tells you oh wait dogs in
heaven you guys we got to keep our eye
on this poor dog yeah the doggy is
really uh it's so cool he's the true
victim in all of this waiting if you
guys think that's a legit way to solve
this
yes the dog like this just just just I
used to do it back in the 17th century
yeah what about them what is the law say
cuz I know you guys went to law school
well it's our property so vacant stares
right oh they're her rights but uh she
doesn't seem to care of up though right
so what do you do as a judge you you
ignore ignore the law I'll be
interesting to see which who the dog
goes to yes yes a we have them both go
come here come here dunno I think
Shannon I think they stood night and you
got to keep it objecting
we're seems like the guys gonna win if
we let the dog decide absolutely yeah
that's out of three
[Laughter]
[Music]